my guest tonight makes his living
reviewing pop songs one-hit wonders and
mostly just god-awful music he goes by
the name Todd in the shadows and he
mostly keeps himself in the shadows even
in the daylight he is the masked man of
mystery and judging by his popularity
he's not gonna show his mug anytime soon
please welcome Todd Nathanson how are
you sir I am doing pretty good glad uh
you flew me out here that's great to be
here um what's with the mask weirdo oh
well um I wanted when I started doing
this I had a real job and one that I did
not you know I I want this following me
around like don't worry calling the
bosses all office one day is like hey we
notice you uh there's videos of you
rubbing cheeseburgers on your chest and
various other stupid things that you
have to do in this business and um well
see ya so that's that's how it started
and I just like the gimmick I'd like the
image of me sideways with a the
silhouette so that's why I don't show my
face and like what's the start I can't
give it up now I can't well I couldn't
do it no I'm not kind of in the big
reveal
right here ya know and it's a it served
me well and everyone's so shocked when
it whenever they see me like oh my god
that's what you look like I'm really
hideous under this uh how did you come
up with the image because it is such a
great image of you at the piano was
silhouetted with the microphone how did
you come up with that image well you
know I do play piano and I'm you know
I've done that for the longest time and
I like doing it and um well you know was
like I always wanted to do it because
you know when I first started he's like
I was really inspired by seeing you know
that
james james rolfe he's a greatest
watching whales but no I'm kidding I
watched I was a huge channel awesome
fans like I could do stuff like that I
could but like they look like I don't
want to show my face but then I got the
idea to do the music is like but I still
don't want to show my face and then it's
like well what if I did it like in
silhouette and like oh man that would
look great
it and it did look great except for the
fact I didn't know how to film anything
but I got I got the way I wanted to look
as far as me being a silhouette like
right right off the bat so it was like
that's why I kept doing it and that's
that's how that came about
does anybody just walking on the street
and you're not wearing the mask do they
recognize you does a1 cover the top of
it is like bad and you're like oh it's
it's Todd not really no no no of course
not oh yeah there's some obsessed people
man I mean you know there's like
obsessed people that could you know
right recognize the lower half well when
I started as I was living a little
nowhere town and uh no one uh no I don't
know if anyone like my little brother
was in the same time he'd spread to his
friends I just cut at the college and
you know some of my friends would tell
you know their friends but unless people
were told they wouldn't know was me so
that was really easy the only reason I
asked this here is because I know people
would kill me if I didn't argue Elvis
Presley yes I am okay I am at a
Nathanson is a fake name my last name is
Presley I am a Presley I'm not the
Presley yeah they descended yes cuz
everyone thinks with the lips and the
chin there that it's Elvis uh yeah I got
my funds like Todd Presley yeah in that
a nice name Nathanson sounds better okay
okay but but still but very present it's
nice that you came out on the show I'm
sure it's not the views will go up
greatly because yeah so thank you for
that
um alright why is there such a love for
taking what's popular and ripping it to
shreds cuz that's mainly what we do yeah
and it is so popular and people enjoy it
so much well it's different for you guys
cuz you do
uh for people to do movies and video
games there's like a pretty clear
standard of what's good and bad and like
you yet people who will defend bad
movies or bad video games but for most
part there's like a pretty solid
consensus of you know Godzilla 98 is
terrible like uh but pop music is
different because all your everyone's a
least favorite song of all times like
the classic worst songs of all time
you're achy breaky hearts and you're uh
who let the dogs out and you light up my
life these are all things that had
billions of fans like so it's way
different than I am so I can take like
the number one song of the countries
like so that something everyone loves
and there's always this gigantic subset
of people that absolutely loathe it
because um because you know it's
different from a movie you watch movies
I go that was crap you walk away but
like a bad song you hear it all the time
especially if you actually listen to the
music what's popular nowadays is stuff
you just can't get away from so uh turns
out there's definitely a market for
people for listening to someone Bosch
what's popular especially in music are
there any songs or groups that you enjoy
that everyone else seems to hate but you
can't help but totally love um I'm not
gonna lie one of my favorite songs like
way up there like not top ten maybe top
20 is Good Vibrations by marky-mark yeah
I would not okay nope it really is I
really intensely adore that song I and I
sighs maybe you can't touch this ass
alright but Good Vibrations by Markus ed
that's the one that's my jam yeah
that's your better than forever
even yeah yeah you're right just a
nostalgic blast from the past isn't it
oh okay well how do you is it just the
songs they were popular or their
specific songs you listen to and you say
I gotta attack that um uh you know it
just kind of builds cuz you know I hear
these songs over and over and over
again and I'll just like he hear us like
a line that strikes me as stupid it was
like huh well more like blah blah blah
and then if I hear it enough I'll get
I'll build up like hundreds of jokes so
that I'll pair down and he's like some
songs I hear that are like oh my god
that's the worst song but I don't have
anything to say about it and then I like
four months later it's like beating me
down so much like okay here you're going
down you gotta get vengeance on ya the
very few songs I know I'm gonna review
right away the first time I heard the
only time that's ever happened is uh and
no one ever no one even knows the song
anymore it was a the 2009 version of we
are the world like you god yeah I don't
even forgot me yeah ya know it everyone
it was already forgotten by the time I
reviewed it and I reviewed it like I I
heard it on a Monday I wrote the script
on a Tuesday I filmed it by the weekend
and it was like I caught that window was
that the one where the gal like all of
it wasn't even like b-list celebrities
it was like f lists Olivia just like sir
at the bottom of the barrel whoever they
could yeah like they opened with Justin
Bieber like at right when he started
getting famous that's already a bad side
like if they even if he was popular like
if they started with him in like now in
2012 that might make sense but in 2009
it was like just like starting with like
I don't know it's just like little Jimmy
Osmond or something just not the best
choice yeah um of course I got asked in
your opinion what is the absolute worst
song you ever heard and why the worst
song I've ever heard and why um like I'm
trying to rank the like the worst song I
know I've reviewed is a song by a
no-name R&B singer named Mario called
break up and every time that anyone
asked me is like yes that is the worst
song I have ever reviewed it's just I
was with Lindsay in a New York bar once
and I've completely forgotten about this
song and they play
it and I wasn't gonna say anything but
Lindsay like look what is this and like
not an hour later they played it again
yes that not much of a movie no no it
wasn't even on a loop they'd usually it
was like a DJ thing so they just like
cut back to it okay it was so popular
they had to play it again
I think the the song that most offend me
is a song from back 2004 called uh
welcome to my life by a horrible
Canadian band called Simple Plan is just
the whiniest most awful most he was like
I'm the only one who feels feelings no
one gets me yeah it's called welcome my
life if that describes I've got to get
the title on yeah that's pretty
pretentious yeah it's it's very teenage
um and of course went as that a guy
asked what's your favorite song and or
group my favorite group I started I
guess I kind of fell out with them just
kind of stopped paying attention then
I've really gotten way back into this
guy his name's Ben Folds you know he's a
piano player and he's very good uh my
favorite song guy I picked when I was 15
it's Everlong by the Foo Fighters and
you know like I'm not gonna I decided
I'm not gonna replace that as Mike you
know like that when you're 15 that's
when you pick it's never gonna be the
same when you're 35 so I think I'm gonna
that's just gonna be my go-to answer for
the rest of my life okay chances are you
get asked that question a lot yeah even
I put a little dirty asking it but it's
like you know I gotta ask you know yeah
we do get asked that all the time when
we're at cons or wherever you you get so
what's your favorite blank what's your
favorite favorite what's your least
favorite and if you watch II anytime any
person on a con gets asked that you can
see their eyes and well not yours
obviously but yes what do you mean
nothing okay
uh obviously you have this huge
connection to music you you adore music
I love music what is it about music that
so quickly and for so long can hold on
to us well what is it with music that
say a movie or a book cannot grab with
us as well I don't I honestly don't know
I I can't I couldn't tell you the
difference between them I just know that
no one like you insult someone's a movie
someone like you can get maybe argue
about it but like you and salt their
music and the gloves are off like you if
you go up to like a muted I don't know
with Radiohead or Muse or whoever your
Beatles say hey your favorite band sucks
like that you you get a harsher reaction
that if you insult a mom it sort of
turns into sports team don't yeah I
solve their teams aren't they of you and
solve their group either so yeah that's
people internalize that a lot like it's
just so it's just so direct like when
you're like say you've got had a really
bad day you come home for a really bad
day from work like are you gonna turn on
Natural Born Killers are going to watch
me angry now you turn up yeah listen to
some angry music look when you or when
you're happy and loved you just met met
so when you're really into you're not
going to sit down and watch Love
Actually or anything
now that is usually the first a time you
feel a major emotion you want to hear
right very much anything yeah um how
does Todd relax um you you really want
to know I gots to know after you asked
do you really want oh well I think about
my dog I Lindsey you know Lindsey she's
got a cute little Boston Terrier and she
doesn't know this but that's my dog now
I took it from really yes and she's the
cutest thing her name's Connie she's a
Boston Terrier she has giant ears like
like like a gremlin and that's how I
relax a matter of fact whenever I'm
stressed out
like being counted 13 our charity drive
is actually really difficult so whenever
I feel like I hey well yeah 15 so what
you don't know is what while I was it
sitting here and I was like I was like
puppy who show cute you show cute in my
mind I gotta lie when you can't see the
eyes your lips look terrifying when you
do that when you go boobies yogi it is
really scary it's frightening ly
adorable at the same time it's the two
together I think that's Kali as well
yeah
no actually it's into her career that is
probably one of the best behaved dogs I
are you kidding don't stop okay okay
wait life with it this way what I met a
lot of dogs that you know will not stay
still will Castley bark will ruin a lot
takes yeah and any time we've had to
film something that dog is in here I
always think to myself oh my god
immediate a crooner this get rid all the
hair it stays quiet
I mean majority of the time every once
in a while it just don't don't Lea
puppy alone that's what all the barking
is giving me will happen but all the
other times it's like usually seem
pretty quiet yeah well yeah when you
walk in the door she'll jump on you but
what she get gets that out of her system
she's fine in a matter of fact I kind of
wish we'd brought her because she'd have
been so cute and we could oh my god it
do doodle it's again the poop dude who's
a cute dog the fuels dog your puppy okay
okay stop or that I might edit it out of
okay so what advice can you give uh to
people at nighttime looking necessarily
do online reviews but just tell jokes or
what if eyes can you give to joke
writers um when you think the script is
done it isn't there is always room for
improvement
like always polish it all you know your
first draft is probably not what the one
you want to go with like and just think
how can i push this even better how can
i push this forward also sit at a piano
and do it in silhouette that's a good
idea
as easy for you yeah I know that my
advice is actually the opposite do
I do what that what your favorite person
is doing like you can take influences
but try your thats the most important
thing do not do what everyone else is
doing
that'll make yourself stick out like you
try to try and find your own take that's
that's what I have to say about that and
if you're doing videos like I am make
sure you focus on everything every bit
is important focus on actually learning
how to film focus on actually learning
how to edit focus on actually learning
on the script focus on actually learning
how to act yeah you got to do all of it
like and I know I'm weaker on some of
these things than others I'm not I have
no idea how to film things like Lindsay
does everything for me now I think I've
actually gotten worse at it um actually
someone from her view say that
convention you said uh if you go for the
obvious joke twenty other people are
gonna go for it too
yeah like what sometimes people ask me
like hey why didn't you say this well
it's like well if you came up with it
like well then what's the point you did
so so to sort go for the different jokes
right over ones that aren't as obvious
yeah that's yeah swerve um I like to end
the interviews with two polar opposite
questions here the first one being what
is the hardest thing professionally or
personally you've ever had to go through
and how did you get through it the the
hardest thing I've ever done goes a
difficult thing of a professional or
personally um I died once I don't
understand really know just anything
well professionally was uh when I
decided I was gonna do this for a living
I didn't I was doing temp jobs at the
time I was looking for a real job and
like but like the more I thought about
like I'm focusing all my energy on doing
this like this is really dumping me
there's no way I can do keep doing this
but I was like no I am I'm just gonna
keep doing this for a while and see
where this takes me
and it took me here next to you right
now
so that was yeah I wish I could have
given you a better something to work
yourself up to yeah this is all you got
it
I've hit the peak you think I'm on the
top of the mountain the shame you can't
see it
I can actually see fairly well through
this like you weren't there on the
charity drive man well I can't read cue
cards we'll also there's a giant light
right there that that helps yeah but
that's it okay granted yeah pretty much
matter because of that yeah and finally
what is the one thing again
professionally or personally that you
are the most proud of that you've ever
done that I am the most proud of
Lindsay pushed me to do this one uh it
was a the Chris Brown episode where I
did not review the song at all like I
was like just so offended by everything
he doesn't like what he says about the
culture and Lindsay pushed me he's like
why don't you just do an episode on him
not even anything about the actual music
which is where I review just review him
I was like yeah I'm gonna do that
because this needs to be said punching
girls ain't cool yo so yeah you know I
like that shouldn't have to be said it
doesn't seem like a nun controversial
opinion you know and especially when I
wasn't even riffing on anything like can
I make be funny with I'm not you know
just like a joke machine like he like
huh that's a stupid line but so that was
a I think I am proud of that so that
that's my answer to that one awesome
this was shut up and talk and my guest
tonight was Todd Nathanson and this is
where we look at your we dance like
we're talking the whole time yeah you
know it was that was that we were doing
oh yeah we're going right into it man
right into it why do they do that why
can't they just like never ever know but
most of the guests wear shoes too but
you know that I think it you know it's
pretty hard to look at those
Lyonne I think I probably have pass out
I was just looking are we still doing
this are like credits rolling like they
going down like I'm just hypnotized by
your feet oh I know aren't they
beautiful like here's a horrible scar